British leaders have spent decades
transforming Great Britain into the
Pakistan of Europe. And we can gauge
their progress, if we want to call it
progress, by considering what just
happened to a woman who thought she was
safe criticizing some of the behavior of
certain Pakistani men in Great Britain,
or as it will eventually be known, New
Pakistan.
Lebna from the YouTube channel Candid
with Lebna took down most of her videos
a few days ago after finding out the
hard way that criticizing jihadis or the
grooming gangs or dwagandists like
Muhammad Hijab can be hazardous to your
existence. Lna's parents are from
Pakistan, so she has an advantage over
some of us and that her claims can't be
dismissed with a wave of the you're a
racist wand. However, her heritage is
also a disadvantage because the people
she's been criticizing view her as a
traitor to her own people and to her own
religion. But let's listen to Lna
explain why she took down her videos.
I'm going to cut to the chase. My life
is at risk. I've taken my videos um down
on both of my channels. I've just left
literally a few of them. And um I'm
still shaking from last night's
experience. I've involved the police and
I can't share everything with you guys
for obvious reasons because it's not
just my supporters watching this. It's
everybody else, the whole world, and
they're not necessarily they don't
necessarily have the best interest.
Lubna doesn't give many details about
what happened, but whatever it was, it
scared her enough to make her instantly
take down most of her content and retire
from talking about anything to do with
Pakistanis and change her location as
quickly as possible. Sadly, the
tolerance levels within the community,
the Muslim and Pakistani community is
generally very, very low. We all know
this. So although my intentions were
good, you know, I was calling it the bad
apples only, not the bad, not the good
ones. I never said anything bad about
the good ones, of course, cuz they're
good. I was talking about the bad people
and I was condemning it because I felt
as if do you know what? Maybe people
think all of us are like this
because I was listening to the feedback
and the feedback was we're not
condemning it enough. So she was calling
out bad behavior in the Pakistani
community because she was listening to
other people and other people were
bothered by the fact that people in the
Pakistani community weren't calling out
this bad behavior. In other words, as an
example, inquiring minds might wonder
why wasn't there an uproar in the
Pakistani community over the Pakistani
grooming gangs? If a bunch of people in
my community were horribly abusing
12-year-old girls, I'd be pretty ticked
off. There would be an uproar from me
and from a lot of other people. So why
wasn't there a massive uproar in the
Pakistani community over what the
Pakistani grooming gangs were doing?
The deafening silence gives the
impression that even the Pakistanis who
weren't involved in the grooming gangs
don't care a whole lot about the
girls. Seems like they just don't care.
That's a really really bad look. So
Lubna realized that this was causing
alarm and she wanted to change the
perception. Didn't work out very well.
the experience that I've had last
night where I had to call the police and
again I can't give details. I I can't
continue talking about the stuff that I
talk about and frankly speaking I don't
want to. No more criticizing anything
anyone in the Pakistani community does.
even though I haven't done any blasphemy
then I've never criticized a religion
even then they just you know they don't
necessarily feel that um I should have a
voice and say what I'm saying so what
I'd like to tell these people that I'm
out I'm not going to be talking about
the Muslim community the Pakistani
community I wish you guys good
luck stop trying to come after me and
harm me I'm a single parent
she's a single mother of two children
which means that threats from people who
know where she lives is a pretty serious
issue.
I've tried my best to bring people
together to be a bridge, but sadly what
this community hears is something else.
What I'm saying and what they're hearing
is completely different. So when they
have no um when they don't want me to
help them, there's no point of me
putting my life at risk. There's some
people who are trying to harm me. This
is seriously messed up. And I don't just
mean because they're threatening her and
trying to harm her. I mean because she
was actually trying to help the
Pakistani community. She was trying to
change people's view of the Pakistani
community by showing that Pakistanis can
call out terrible behavior in their
community. But how did that work out?
They're trying to harm me. And of course
I I did call the police last year were
online threats but this
time where people are trying to I
believe they have found me. Okay. I
believe they know where I live and
there's a something that's happened last
night where um which I can't talk about.
The police came to my
house and I need to move basically. I
need to get out of here. By popular
demand, she did set up a GoFundMe so she
can move immediately. The link is in the
description box. The reason why from
this community, lots of people, you
know, a lot of you guys complain, why
are more people not coming out from this
community? Why are they not condemning?
This is the reason why you're the first
to get
attacked. In our western minds, this is
no reason to kill someone. But sadly,
the psychology of some of the people
that we're dealing with is the tolerance
is so low. Like in their minds, you've
done enough that they can take your
life. Like they will justify it. Sadly,
that's not just Pakistani culture, Lna.
That's Islam.
Yes. I would like the extremists to
know. Fantastic. You've won. Okay. Good
luck. Please don't come after me. I'm a
single parent. I don't have money right
now. I left my job to build these
YouTube channels. I really genuinely
thought I'm doing something good. Okay.
Now, if you guys don't appreciate or
whatever, you guys think you can take
someone's life when I'm trying to help.
Lna says that the extremists won. Well,
they may have won their battle to
silence Lna, but they've still got the
rest of us to deal with. And I have to
say, it's things like this that make us
blast away at Muhammad and the Quran
even harder. So, did they really win?
The problem is when you say something
where you're trying to improve the
community, the community thinks you're
the enemy and then anyone who's outside
the community who's not a Muslim, who's
not Pakistani, they also see me
potentially as an enemy cuz they think
I'm Muslim Pakistani, right? So you get
bashed from both sides. As someone who's
been getting blasted for years by
Muslims for criticizing Islam and by
atheists for being a Christian and by
Christians for being too mean when I
respond to Muslims and atheists. I know
what it feels like. Lna,
it's not worth it. Seriously, it's not
worth it. I wish the British native
English people good luck. This is, you
know, your country, your your ancestors,
whatever. You know, this is your
heritage. They fought for this country.
I've done my part. I'm sorry. I don't
feel safe in this country.
A Pakistani British woman doesn't feel
safe from Pakistanis in Great Britain.
I've been hearing things like that a
lot. I've been hearing from people,
especially Christians and ex-Muslims,
who fled Muslim countries, hoping for a
better life in Great Britain, only to
find out they're just not safe in Great
Britain.
This is supposed to be UK. I'm supposed
to feel safe here. I don't feel safe in
this
country. where people think that they
can get away with harming me because
this is what's happened to these
countries become so like you know we're
just anything anything can happen. Sorry
LNA but the UK will gladly hand you over
to these guys just like they handed over
tens of thousands of young British girls
to them. British leaders have become
thoroughly pagan. Their new god is
tolerance. And tolerance, their new god,
demands
sacrifice. You're the latest to be
tossed on the altar. Love. In fact,
British leaders aren't just willing to
sacrifice you and tens of thousands of
young British girls. They're willing to
sacrifice the rest of the British
population, the British legal system,
and the entire nation. What better way
to demonstrate your undying devotion to
tolerance than by tolerating the most
insanely intolerant culture on the
planet. What do we know about Pakistan?
Three things. First, we know that lots
of men in Pakistan think it's perfectly
acceptable to kidnap Christian and Hindu
girls and to do whatever they want with
them.
British leaders saw this and said, "Hey,
let's bring in hundreds of thousands of
men who think like this and give them
open access to an endless supply of
young British girls."
Second, we know that police in Pakistan
are quite frequently either complicit in
these kidnappings or they're too scared
to do anything about them because if
they take the side of Christian or Hindu
girls, they'll be viewed as traitors and
they'll be targeted as enemies of
Islam. Once again, British leaders saw
this and said, "Hey, let's bring in
hundreds of thousands of men who
intimidate the authorities into not
protecting victims." And what was the
result? Great Britain now has a two-tier
justice system, just like
Pakistan. Third, we know that in
Pakistan, it's pretty simple to silence
anyone. If you don't like what someone
says, all you have to do is start
shouting, "Help! Help! This man insulted
our religion and a violent mob will
assemble and deal with the person.
British leaders saw this and said, "Hey,
let's bring in hundreds of thousands of
men who silence critics through
violence."
Lna is the latest victim, but she
definitely won't be the last because
British leaders keep bringing in more of
these guys and the Pakistani community
has way higher birth rates than the
native British
population. Sucks that no one warned the
good people of Great Britain about this.
Oh wait, we did. And you called us
racist, islamophobic, hatemongering
bigots for trying to help you. You
attacked the people who were trying to
help you just as the community Lubna was
trying to help attacked her. And so all
I can say to you is exactly what Lna
said to her community. I wish you guys
good luck. I wish the British native
English people good luck. Good luck. I
wish the Pakistani community good luck.
I wish the Muslim community good luck.
If you'd like to watch Lebno's full
video, the link is in the description
box.
[Music]